i hope you like memes
or the next few minutes will get very
awkward
means our internet's lingua franca so as
a video game scholar but also a geek i
will borrow them to talk about something
you might probably have heard about
the metaverse
john
i'm sorry i don't have the license for
that sound
i know i know
siphon fans will be leaving comments on
this video the metaverse is not a new
idea
in fact as a death premier i want to
showcase my research on 30 years of the
metaverse from its inception
to its current trajectory
that's right the metaverse is already on
fire and we even have not built it yet
that's efficiency
how can this happen
think of the metaverse as a frankenstein
made of different parts of current
internet and digital technologies
now with 3d visuals and touch
between our physical reality and virtual
reality there are different layers of
mixed and augmented reality
where physical and digital objects plan
the metaverse will be somewhere across
the spectrum that i call the reality
gradient
but we shouldn't let the 3d smoke and
mirrors distract us from the fact that
the metaverse is the internet
and as such it will inherit the worst
trade of its current business models
with premium access to our bodies br
headsets and sensors can extract huge
amount of involuntary data that we can
control
like harvests or blinks
this will get even worse with
neurotechnology allowing to read and
modify our brains creating a capitalism
of cognitive surveillance
we don't certainly want the metaverse to
become the bad sequel to the internet
so
how do we fix it
even before we build it
by avoiding repeating past internet
mistakes
understanding why we're building it
who consists control of it and what
makes it different
huge questions and little time so let's
focus on one key ingredient for
metaverse success
connection
as a scholar connection means that the
metaverse needs an architecture linking
all the meta verses together in a way
that we can travel across them
seems easy because champion website is
already an internet feature
but that is because we don't carry our
digital belongings with us
you can take your instagrams likes to
tiktok or your roblox avatar to fortnite
to achieve that we need content
portability which is a very difficult
engineering task
one that requires an object to function
and look consistently across different
software environments
but guess what it's also a lawyering
problem
because you need a complex structure of
contracts to legally copy a digital
object
just between ourselves let me tell you a
little intellectual property secret
our digital goods are treated
differently from their tangible
counterparts
instead of ownership we have
a license to use them crafty limited by
terms of service
in the physical world something called
copyright exhaustion allow us to resell
our goods
but courts don't agree if that applies
to digital content
and without this digital exhaustion rule
exiting one metaverse will be like going
through a very strict custom
one that will confiscate all your
possessions if you want to get through
so
connection in the metaverse means
interoperability
a coherent system of legal and technical
standards for true decentralization
nfts and blockchain can provide the
technical tools but it will never work
without the legal counterpart
as an activist
connection means that the metaverse is
the people
the communities that will breed life
and populate these worlds
without humanity the metaverse will be
just a 3d ghost town
but not everyone will be there
because we are not born equal into the
metaverse
we are promised boundless worlds but in
fact we will be as free as we can afford
to pay
we need to find ways to create an
inclusive metabolism one that keeps the
best things of humanity online
kindness creativity
cat memes
this is not wishful thinking kindness is
a powerhouse
there is initiatives like leyline
creating a blockchain proof of good
deeds or charity marathons like games
done quick
a game about sending anonymous letter to
strangers
might seem like a recipe for disaster
but against all odds over one million
letters full of kindness were shared
people want to do good
and now we have the technical means to
escalate it to unprecedent levels
the metaverse might still be a work in
progress
but that means we still have room and a
chance to influence what it will become
open accessible and inclusive
it's not every day that humanity has the
chance to create a new reality
so my limitation to you
let's make it a good one thank you read
you in the comments